[Applause]
versus
yeah this is not gonna happen right but
people are calling for it
usher versus chris brown i want to see
this happen
i'll be honest with you i don't know if
chris is [ __ ] with us
he's not at all and that's why i want to
see it happen bro chris we need to sleep
on usher yo
yo really take it back
you're out of your mind really take it
back
think about bangers for bangers and
diversity of
bangers usher is everything from [ __ ]
edm music
to like soulful love ballads to like
half rap half singing shits come
on bro i don't know if chris listen is
chris
more talented yes overall more talented
was a better
dancer he's a better actor for whatever
that's worth
but he's not a better singer you don't
have a better voice he's not a better he
don't have hits
no chris brown's got a lot of hits bro
yeah
i got some famous if we're talking about
those hits chris brown got it
yeah he's got some hits yeah we're
talking about music it's
not even close dog are you forgetting my
way
my way nice and slow you make me want to
offer you make me
want us you remind me of 87. you remind
me of a girlfriend
you don't have to call their confessions
8701 no that was before
8-7 over here i stand 8704
also not
[Laughter]
that was a prolonged pause bro that [ __ ]
was pregnant
he had that song with uh who's the
[ __ ] will i am oh my god i am oh my
god was it son
what else what are some other ones what
are the other good ones just play
confessions
all your confessions you play all the
way through bro
yeah you guys what other ones christians
are not naming any hits from your name
he's had bangers from the start of his
career till even this day he's name a
single head he just had
one started 10 12 years later he was
later banging last year
he's talking man
he can't listen to it
name some songs that there's fire that
alex probably doesn't just name mad
songs
name another name confessions
yeah yeah yeah see how fire is that
yes yeah asha
he's one of my favorite artists he has a
bunch of bangers but chris will name one
song bigger than yeah
can i keep it a buck with y'all right
now none of them [ __ ] with john
mayer's
yeah that's a good point bro yo none of
them [ __ ] with john
that's a good thing no white people have
lousy lunch at the tlg when this pretty
girl came and she sat next to me
never thinks ever the way she did and
she do it she does that she do it a good
day
john mayer or mr az jason moraz oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
got me out of a breakup bro i was in a
dark place and
and jason murray's took me out i
remember that's two songs
say what you got more than two no no no
no no no don't be disrespectful don't be
disrespectful where's his hand
say what where's his hand where is it
the cursed side prophet with my hand in
my pocket and i'm waiting for the time
of them
yo jason i saw him at carnegie hall
barefoot [ __ ] performed barefoot
fedora
fedora yep yeah i'm saying giant
hawaiian next to him
that's kind of fire it's illegal
i'm saying but back to this i truly
believe
usher has slept on and this is what
always [ __ ] happens in these verses
is
the older person yes gets slept on
because the
there's like the relevancy bias or
something like recency bias right
recency bias kicks in you forget how
many joints usher had
he's gonna be playing songs and
literally we're gonna you're gonna
realize you know the word to every
single one of them songs
it's not even gonna be close i would and
i'll notice the words the
chris brown name five chris brown songs
son
explain this massive flaw in your logic
you think dmx beats snoop
dmx i love dmx has not been relevant
since 2002 2003
18 years ago but you give a [ __ ] about
all his songs from 1999. that's new york
bias
because i didn't listen to any of
snoop's earlier albums until i was older
why is dmx in the battle at all why do
people like dmx why do they think it was
close at all
snoop was relevant for decades after dmx
was they both made powerful music
when but dmx hasn't done anything in
decades decades
you got it no i'm saying it's a good
point it's going to be close i just
think chris takes it uh yeah
i think i beat him like he was karuchi
what
what nah he didn't beat karushi you
don't think he didn't be croochy
chris brown yeah i can't put two on him
what let me tell you something if i put
if you got if you put one on yourself
i could put two on you fair so didn't
she file a restraining order or some
[ __ ] like that
she did i don't think so mark can you
look into that yeah she's cute bro
she's cute she's cute
she is kayuchi nah she's she's
what's up with usher what's up with
usher uh
giving that fat girl the her oh big deal
that's why
she was already ushering herself into
diabetes who gives a [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah krucci won a five-year restraining
order against chris brown i'm sure he
was great
i could put two on him i'm gonna be
honest he probably put he probably more
than two on her
yo and she stayed around yeah
she made a whole career out of being
chris brown's girlfriend
remember that joke by chappelle where he
said uh
bill clinton is famous that's famous
imagine you could suck somebody's dick
and they're famous
yeah somebody sucks a dick and then they
become famous
hold on girl there's a what is there's a
future in it suck my dick there's a
future in it yeah
that's different level of fame like that
girl did nothing
besides be chris brown's girlfriend
and she got a tv show yeah and be cute
she's very cute i think very cute also
helps
[Applause]
yes